they tell me it's unwarranted it's
unjustifiable
they acknowledge that we should not let
our potential adversaries Russia China
North Korea Iran gain access to such
dangerous Technologies
but they see no reason why the human
race can't be told what they tell me is
the truth which is Iran nihis non-human
intelligences that have been engaging
with this planet for many many thousands
of years thousands not tens of thousands
oh well I can't specify tens of
thousands I've just you know it would be
more than tens of thousands I mean
they've been with us for for time
immemorial I'm told
now Millions
that's your that's your words my friend
I don't know I don't know for sure but
the the simple fact is
I'm kind of
I'm bored with this debate at the moment
you know I I I I don't care anymore I
just think
you know people
there's a fundamental failure here of
oversight I know a lot of people are
going to get excited with what this new
legislation says and I want to deal with
that because I think it's important that
we talk about it
but I have a gut feeling that congress's
heart is not in this
and that the lobby the powerful military
Lobby that wants this suppressed is
winning
and sure enough they've got their shills
out there and social media they've got
their friends in the media you know
every National Security correspondent is
being told on the QT stay away from this
one on the QT on the quiet
um
um can you explain how this works
yeah sure I mean I mean I mean I've
reported on National Security issues the
thing I find hilarious is let's use an
analogy let's talk about what happened
at the time of the last Gulf War shortly
after the al-Qaeda attacks 2002-2003.
for some reason that has never been even
now fully properly explained
Al-Qaeda became Iraq
and Afghanistan and we ended up
launching totally disastrous Wars into
both of those countries based on
intelligence from
sources okay
now ask yourself
credulous National Security reporters
who have since been hung out to drive
for their failure to do their job
properly accepted assurances from the
CIA from Cole Powell and his testimony
to the UN this was an important moment
where the world was essentially strict
into going to war against Saddam Hussein
on the false claim that he had weapons
of mass destruction in the Iraqi desert
that was all sourced back largely in
part to one guy called curveball that
was his code name curveball a guy based
I think somewhere in Germany who was a
refugee and it turned out he was a put
up by the Iraqi National Congress who
were essentially
um a group that were largely aligned
with Iran
and because of
credulous National Security reporters
not doing their job
a source led the world to war in the
Middle East
trillions of dollars have been expended
in an unnecessary War hundreds of
thousands of lives of good people have
been lost
in unnecessary War
now the problem with that was you had
largely American journalists but also
British and Australian journalists and I
cut myself in this as well I was
involved in doing some of these stories
you know we credulously accepted the
assurances that the Americans were
giving that there were weapons of mass
destruction in the Iraqi desert and that
there had to be an engagement with
Saddam Hussein to bring this to a
resolution to stop this evil man from
doing these terrible things
the reality was that it soon emerged
within a few weeks of the invasion that
there weren't these wmds the whole
pretext for the war was wrong the
intelligence was wrong
so you have a double standard here you
have the media back in 2003 what's that
18 years ago credulously accepting a
assurances from the national assure
security establishment but oh yeah we
should believe our sources yeah yeah we
should go to war in the Middle East
absolutely
now we've got a situation where a highly
reputable credible intelligence Source
somebody who personally hand delivered
the presidential daily briefings from
the national geospatial agency directly
to the West Wing of the White House
entrusted with two thousand special
access programs goes public and makes
very dramatic and yeah I'm sure quite
ontologically shocking claims about an
nhi presence an alien presence on this
planet
and how many stories have you seen in
the news sections of the New York Times
The Washington Post or any of the TV
networks ABC CBS NBC
not one the only stories that have run
in the New York Times or the Washington
Post are doubting op-ed pieces run by
opinion writers that are very easily
marginalized you just watched a clip
from the theories of everything channel
for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy